Christina I think that you see I think
the role of women if you put faith
alongside globalization I do think it
has some quite radical aspects in that
about the role of women because
globalization as I say doesn't really
it's it is ultimately a liberating force
in that sense I mean it's got all its
negatives but as I say one thing it does
so for example in the work that my wife
does with her foundation which is about
the empowerment of women and
particularly the use of technology to
help empower women you know mobile
telephony and the internet and so on I
mean it is you know you will find faith
communities that have say let us say a
very conservative view of the role of
women that once you start once they
start being involved in the process of
globalization some of those attitudes
just become well first of all they
become counterproductive economically
and then the women start not to put up
with it right so I actually think there
is a real chance to do that one of the
things that we some of the universities
doing this faith in globalization course
focus very much the University of
Singapore for example because very much
on the role of women in religion and the
different faiths and their attitudes to
it and so on and I think it's a
fascinating and important part of it